I am very thankful
for the NBA for
giving me this huge
platform worldwide.
But, if they're going
to do something
wrong
I'm going to
expose them.
When should
professional athletes
feel morally obligated
to put their careers
their personal safety
and their own
freedom on the line
to speak out about
political injustice?
Raised in Turkey,
Enes Kanter Freedom
decided to use his fame
to speak out
about the issues
that matter most.
While we are dribbling the ball
on the other
side of the world,
people are losing
their loved ones
and their lives
and losing their hopes.
Freedom made headlines earlier
this year
for criticizing
the National
Basketball Association
and its biggest stars
for their business
relationships
with China,
which has been accused
of violating the
civil rights
of ethnic Muslims
known as the Uyghurs,
and forcing them into
reeducation camps.
Reason caught up
with Freedom
to talk about
his early
childhood
growing up in Turkey
as a basketball
prodigy,
calls for his arrest,
and what's
driving his activism.